hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you a website where you can get royalty
free music that you can use to put in
the background of your tutorials or of
your uh your unboxing videos or
something
so you might have heard other youtubers
use this website and use music from this
website in their video so i'm going to
pull it up here it's
incompetect.com up here is the url with
their little logo
www.incompetech.com
so the link will be in the description
wherever that is so go ahead and check
it out and basically um at the top of
the website you can search the website
so if you want to search a tacky one or
if you want to search a smooth
music or something you can search that
at the top of the website but basically
they offer a lot of different themes of
music different themed music
so if we scroll down here there are uh
obviously credits to the author but this
is royalty free music so um let's find
one that we like and we'll just click on
it
and it'll bring us to the page where you
can pro where we can preview it so
you'll see here it says you can show
preview and download so first of all um
it'll say it's highly processed piano
and instrumentation it's length genre
title all that we hit show preview and
it comes out with the uh the little
quicktime uh toolbar here so i'm just
going to hit play
and this is basically how you can hear
the preview
sounds pretty cool if we do want to
download this then we just hit that
download button right there and then
safari or firefox or whatever in our
browser you're using just hit the open
button so you can save it so it's
already done downloading it is in an mp3
format so all the music you get from
this website will be an mp3 so if we uh
open the containing folder here just by
right-clicking it and opening containing
folder or i'm in safari just hit the
little magnifying glass
this is actually where they saved it now
it is in a temporary folder so you're
not going to be able to find it
instantly i'm just going to cut
cut it and paste it some place i can
remember like the my music folder or the
desktop so i'm going to go ahead and
paste it on the desktop
and there it is we can rename it add all
the credits to it and everything and
there we go we have that music for free
now when you're using the music you get
off in
incompetech.com make sure you include
in the description music um
royalty mute
royalty free music provided by
incompetech.com something like that in
the description i'll try to put some uh
soft music in the background of this
tutorial so you can hear an example of
what it looks like but basically i'm
actually i might not because i'm using
my new microphone here still trying to
get a chance to use it but there you go
that's basically um where i get royalty
free music i've saved it as a bookmark
up here as royalty-free music i couldn't
write the whole thing but there there
you go so i hope you enjoy this tutorial
and you have your music on your desktop
right there so i hope you like this one
thanks for watching and please subscribe
if you haven't already and if you have
any requests feel free to subscribe and
pm me and i'll try to get to a video or
try to answer your question as soon as i
can so thanks for watching peace